recently we got one of Hollywood's  biggest celebrities to sit down with us  and share some stories from behind the  scenes of his movies his TV shows in his  life these stories have never been heard  before  this is an exclusive I think you're  gonna like it take a look T  in Rocky three my character's name was  clubber Lang I wanted it to be keep  seeing my sunshine the producer said  nope  that made me sad see great people wonder  why I call myself mr. t when dude that's  does the T stands were tough  I said no another dude would asked if  the T stands for my last name to rot no  it does not  the T and mr. T stands for tuna mmm do  you love dunno see I remember when I  guest-starred on Diff'rent Strokes I  said to the director when do I get to do  my scene with Tootie  he said no man that's a different show I  never did get to do that scene with 2d T  [Applause]